قال الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم الفيفا انه
تم الاتفاق على تشغيل رحلات الطيران
المؤقته بين تل ابيب ودوحه طوال فتره
بطوله كاس العالم واضاف الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم ان الاتفاق يتيح للمشجعين
لساليين والفلسطينيين زياره قطر وحضور
المباريات خلال فتره كاس العالم من نجاه
قال متحدث باسم بطوله كاس العالم انه منذ
فوز قطر بحقوق استضافه كاس العالم اكدت
جميع حاملي تذاكر سيكونون قادرين على حضور
المباريات في قطر واكدا ان اعلان اليوم هو
التزام قطر باحترام سياسات الفيفا
وبمتطلبات الاستضافه فقال مسؤول قطري ان
الفلسطينيين سيتما كانون الان من
الاستمتاع باول بطوله لكاس العالم في
العالم العربي والاسلامي بمجام الاتفاق
التي ابرمته
واكد ان موقف قطر من التطبيع لم يتغير ولا
يزال موقفها مرتبطه ارتباطا بحل القضيه
الفلسطينيه كما اكد انه ما ابلاغه
الاسرائيليين ان اي تصعيد في القدس
المحتله او الضفه الغربيه او غزه يمكن ان
يؤدي الى الغاء الاتفاق بما في ذلك
الرحلات المباشره